hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
a thousand songs in your pocket that's
what Steve Jobs famously said at an
Apple event back in 2001.
he went on to hold out a white device
the size of a deck of cards that could
store and play an entire music library
without a hitch
it was Unthinkable at the time as 20 or
30 songs was the norm for a Flash MP3
player but a thousand songs is what
Apple promised and delivered in the form
of the iPod
many of you watching have owned an iPod
in one form or another and probably have
fond memories of it
but last year Apple discontinued the
iconic product that brought the company
back from the brink of collapse
the original iPod was a Pioneer in terms
of a simple design an easy to use
functionality but did you know that the
iPod was designed and manufactured in
just a few months and also in a strange
legal case Apple credited the idea of
the iPod to an obscure Man by the name
of Ken Kramer in this episode we'll look
at all of that and how the original iPod
was so critical for apple and the music
industry
thank you you are watching cold fusion
TV
[Music]
this is a total solution if an iPod
firewire iTunes with all your music in
it it all works together seamlessly
normally Apple can do that is to make
the hardware the software and all the
technology that allows us to solve
problems for people that no one else
would dare take on the story of the
making of the first iPod started with
seemingly unrelated incidents as you'll
see a string of events and technological
innovations would fall exactly in the
right places to make it happen
it all started in the late 1990s after
11 years in Exile Steve Jobs would
return to Apple in 1997. the company was
going through a financial crisis and
jobs was brought back in hopes that
he'll be able to steer the company in
the right direction Apple also needed
some fresh ideas to make a mark at the
Turning of the 20th century
it was the dawn of the internet and the
whole world was going digital so upon
his return to keep up with modern times
Steve Jobs adopted a digital Hub
strategy the idea was to combine Apple
Hardware software and services so that
users could have a uniform platform for
their digital lifestyle in a nutshell an
ecosystem where everything works
seamlessly and as you all know very well
Apple's ecosystem became an integral
part of the company's future but as for
now the idea was in its infancy
the focal point of this digital Hub was
the iMac but interestingly Steve Jobs
would realize the untapped potential of
the firewire port this standard Digital
Data bus was developed by Apple in the
late 1980s and was used for many years
by Apple themselves and other companies
like Sony
firewire could connect devices like
camcorders and digital cameras to
computers
its main benefit was the speed it could
transfer data at a significantly faster
rate almost 30 times faster than any
other standard at the time
this rate was 400 megabits per second
laughable now but at that time it was a
big deal
Steve Jobs decided to include firewire
in the iconic translucent iMac G3 which
was released in 1998.
Apple thought that the inclusion of
firewire would allow users to easily
transfer videos shot with their digital
camcorders and edit them on their
computers
but as it turned out people were much
more interested in music
in the 90s the internet was taking over
the world people were increasingly
sharing files and information online but
sharing music files was still difficult
in the early 90s as Internet speeds were
ridiculously slow music was typically
ripped from CDs and file sizes were huge
but some researchers at The fraunhofer
Institute in Munich Germany had some
ideas
after four years of difficult work they
created a brand new file format and of
course you've heard of it it's called
MP3
it significantly reduced the size of
music files without compromising on
audio quality
the rise of the MP3 file format caused a
lot of commotion in the music industry
first of all it became very easy for
everyone to rip their CDs into MP3 files
and store them on their computers
the time was just right for a little
device to come along and allow people to
take these files with them on the go
by 1998 MP3 players like the MP man
F-100 from Elga labs and the Diamond Rio
pmp3 300 had hit the market both were
bulky could barely play 30 minutes of
music and cost more than 200 dollars
but they became popular as people just
loved portable music
and then the floodgates would open
peer-to-peer file sharing sites would
allow people to download music for free
one application Napster became an
overnight sensation it became so popular
that it got into legal disputes with one
of the biggest heavy metal bands
Metallica
overall the entire music industry took a
big hit and record labels were losing
millions in Revenue
everybody recognized though that the
future of music distribution was in
digital format
it's quite interesting to think about
how one Innovation can snowball into
another and cause a major disruption in
the process
[Music]
meanwhile during the growing frenzy of
digital music Apple saw a huge gap in
its digital Hub strategy to fill that
void Apple brought sound Jam MP it was a
popular MP3 encoding and Playback
application
three of its Engineers were also brought
to Apple they would transform sound jam
into iTunes
jobs wanted iTunes to seamlessly
transfer music files from computers to
MP3 players
however while investigating this the
Apple team found the vast majority of
players to be useless they were either
too expensive too bulky too small or too
clunky to use
and transferring music files from
computers was painfully slow
this was a crucial moment when Steve
Jobs saw an opportunity
as an avid music fan himself he planned
to create a small portable MP3 player
that could store hundreds of songs and
play CD quality music
he wanted the player to work well with
iTunes to potentially attract more
customers to the Mac platform
at the end of 2000 jobs had assigned
John Rubinstein to the task Rubenstein
joined Apple in 1997. he was the
company's Hardware engineering Chief and
Steve Jobs most trusted Hardware advisor
he recognized that Apple already had
most of the components needed to make an
MP3 player the firewire port could solve
the transfer speed problem other parts
could be sourced from in-house Hardware
departments or outside suppliers there
was only one problem flash storage was
too expensive so a hard drive was the
only option how were they going to find
a hard drive that was small enough but
also had a high enough capacity
as luck would have it in February of
2001 Rubenstein found such a device a
hard drive with a 5 gigabyte capacity
he just happened to be visiting Toshiba
in Japan when he found it
the Toshiba Engineers didn't know what
they could use it for but this was a
game changer for Rubenstein now a player
could be made with a small form factor
and higher capacity
he immediately purchased the riots for
10 million dollars after getting
permission from Steve Jobs of course
a lot of people don't know this but a
couple of years earlier in 1999 the
computer company Compaq had the same
idea as Apple but they used a laptop
hard drive it did provide 4.8 gigabytes
of capacity storage but at 799 dollars
it wasn't cheap and it ended up being
very bulky
foreign
[Music]
would hire Tony Fidel to work further on
this project Fidel had previously worked
for General magic and Phillips
electronics and hence he had plenty of
experience developing handheld devices
such as pdas and palm tops when Fidel
came to Apple in February of 2001 he was
given only six weeks to present a
prototype
it was such a difficult situation for
him because there was no research no
previous design or not even a team to
help him out
however he stuck with it and managed to
develop three concepts on his own
in mid-april 2001 he presented his
prototypes to Apple Executives including
Steve Jobs
during that same meeting Apple's head of
product marketing Phil Schiller
suggested the iconic design of a
mechanical scroll wheel it wasn't a
novel concept as he drew his inspiration
from other devices such as the bang
Olufsen Buick on phone
but Sheila correctly believed that users
could scroll through hundreds of songs
much faster with the wheel than the
methods of the other MP3 players such as
up and down buttons and he was right
anyone who watched anyone else used an
MP3 player in the early 2000s would
remember just how tedious it was to get
through a song list
with the basic concept in place Fidel
was given a full-time job at Apple
he only had six months from the end of
April to October within that time he had
to form a team develop a product get it
manufactured and push it out the door
Apple Engineers were tied down with Mac
projects so Fidel had to assemble a team
of 25 regulars and contractors from the
outside some came from his startup
company fuse and a few veteran Engineers
joined from General magic and Phillips
due to time constraints Fidel's team had
to adopt a collaborative approach
a Silicon Valley startup portal player
provided the specialized MP3 playing
chipset
a cupentino company named pixo supplied
the basic OS Jeff Robin an interface
designer Tim Wasco transformed the OS
into a high-level user interface and
music playing software in-house
expertise helped with the power supply
and display and apple already had that 5
gigabyte Toshiba disk a battery from
Sony and firewire to meet the deadline
all team members were required to work
18 to 20 hours per day seven days a week
as you can imagine it cost them dearly
in their personal lives according to
Fidel it was so tough that he had to
break up with his girlfriend at the time
meanwhile Apple's design team led by
Jonathan Ive would work on the design
process jobs insisted on not doing too
much with the product he wanted the
device to be functional but simple but
also as small as humanly possible
Johnny ive's team settled on a modest
box the size of a deck of cards and this
was after creating a dozen prototypes
they used white polycarbonate on the
front of the device and stainless steel
on the back it was a minimalist form
reminiscent of the brawn T3 pocket radio
the brainchild of Dita Rams a German
industrial designer
Johnny Ive had always admired Rams for a
sleek and modular design aesthetic
the name iPod was suggested by a
freelance copywriter Vinnie Chico from
San Francisco
jobs frequently mentioned Apple's
digital Hub concept while discussing the
player
the Mac was the hub for the host of
other gadgets and Chico compared The Hub
to a spaceship while other smaller
vessels as in pods would come in and out
to feed off it when he saw a prototype
the white design struck a chord with him
he came up with the word pot by drawing
inspiration from the film 2001 A Space
Odyssey the prefix I was added to match
with the iMac
after six months of painstakingly hard
work the device was finally ready on
October 23rd 2001 Steve Jobs revealed
the iPod to the world
despite its 399 price tag people love
the device and it quickly became a
status symbol for coolness
with a 1 000 song capacity it was a Leap
Forward for MP3 players
but contrary to popular belief it wasn't
an immediate Smash Hit Steve Jobs was
adamant that the iPod should only be
available for Mac
he thought the product was so compelling
that people would jump ship and dive
right into the Apple ecosystem but what
it ended up doing was alienating a huge
Market upper management eventually
convinced jobs that it should be
available on Windows as well and From
This Moment the iPod really took off
the iPod would pave the way for Apple's
future dominance in the music industry
Apple launched the ITN store and now
users could buy individual tracks for 99
cents instead of purchasing an entire
album iTunes would go on to dominate 70
of the legal download market at its peak
in 2007. despite the figures it was
insignificant for Apple because iTunes
served only as a driver to its main cash
cow
the iPod
the iPod is single-handedly turned the
Apple company around selling over 100
iPods a minute it fixed their financial
situation and also made the company cool
again from the floundering company it
was in the 1990s
okay so what about that cane Kramer guy
the guy who Apple credited as inventing
the iPod well I have done a full episode
on it but essentially Apple was in a
lawsuit with burst.com during the
proceedings Apple produced some
documentation that labeled Kane Kramer
the father of the iPod due to his
invention of the concept of the MP3
player and a store analogous to iTunes
all the way back in 1979
I'll leave a full link to that episode
Down Below
foreign
[Music]
conclusion Apple sold more than 400
million iPods before discontinuing the
brand last year the iPod mini Shuffle
Nano and touch came in all different
shapes colors sizes and had different
features but every generation of iPod
shared the same ethos Simplicity and
functionality the iPod did give Apple
the means to create the iPhone which
eventually would become Apple's greatest
selling product however the iPod's
Legacy will live on so for me personally
I do find the story of the iPod quite
interesting what do you guys think let
me know in the comments section below
anyways that's about it from me my name
is the gogo and you have been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
foreign
Fusion it's new thinking